children's behavior is often very
different than adults they spend more
time indoors they spend most of their
time very close to the ground and little
kids are always putting things into
their mouths so that if there are
pesticides sprayed indoors probabilities
that they would be exposed to more of
those and adults would for a variety of
physiological and behavioral reasons
they're often at higher risk than adults
are to contaminants in the environment
jaanwar go is professor of environmental
policy and risk analysis he's found that
many environmental hazards permitted by
the federal government have long
endangered Public Health with the most
vulnerable and exposed being children I
became extremely interested thinking
about this historically and wondered
whether or not there was there were
large scale patterns at play why were
children neglected why did they face
higher risks from air pollutants
drinking water pollutants indoor air
quality problems in addition to
pesticides Green intelligence is a book
that allowed me to synthesize many ideas
that I've developed over the past couple
of decades I think that that was the
purpose of the book to to ask that
question whether or not 20th century law
really was protective of children's and
women's health and the answer is clearly
no we're seeing an epidemic of illness
among children that is developmentally
and neurologically defined so attention
deficit disorder is one good example of
that and also we're seeing similar
problems in those areas among the
elderly in terms of increased incidence
of Alzheimer's disease and dimensions
thinking about that one I think should
think about the kinds of chemicals that
one is exposed to as they move through
their life and many of these compounds
assault the central nervous system the
point I'm making is that that our
nervous systems are under assault from
the time that were conceived until the
time that we die and we need to think
about how to how to manage our exposure
to these chemical mixtures and what I
came to realize and explain in this book
green intelligence is that that the
indoor spraying of pesticides can lead
to exposures that are quite serious and
people have the expectation that it's
okay to release these chemicals in an
indoor environment so there a couple of
points to keep in mind and one is that
many of these chemicals have not been
tested to figure out what their their
fate is indoors in other words how long
they
syst how long they take to break down
what actually happens to the material
it's sprayed indoors and this is
problematic especially for young kids
that may spend a large amount of time in
the house or an apartment or schools are
routinely sprayed cafeterias are
routinely sprayed EPA's attention has
been directed more than ninety percent
to contaminants outdoors that that's
something that we need to remedy
exposure to unregulated chemicals is a
huge uncontrolled experiment companies
that manufacture hazardous chemicals
should be responsible for proving their
safety before they are sold I think that
we need we need international agreement
and national agreement among major
chemical producing nations this has been
a fundamental flaw in our legal system
is the absence of prior testing so the
number of chemicals in the international
marketplace is now closed 80,000 and
fewer than seven percent of those had
been tested to understand their basic
toxicity let alone their environmental
fate so what that means is we we don't
know where they are in our environment
and we haven't tested them to know how
dangerous they are it is now impossible
to avoid exposure to plastics they
pervade our homes our food our water and
our bodies despite the the enormity of
plastic production the chemical
companies enjoy you know virtual absence
of regulation and testing requirements
right now we have an area twice the size
of Texas known as the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch where the currents and the
Pacific have concentrated plastic wastes
the light plastics that are floating
near the surface and gradually breaking
down and being mistaken as phytoplankton
and consumed by fish and moving up the
food chain we're catching the fish and
we're eating the fish but we're also
eating the plastics we need to have some
sense of responsibility about the
ultimate fate of these
I think that Yale is it's a terrific
place to study environmental science and
and also the various problems that we
face globally and nationally so if you
want to study human relations with the
environment I think this is a great
place to do it for more information
about the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies visit environment
yale edu
you